and that's already started yeah  can you make sure but i think so  yeah we can do it  ready to lose  okay i'll be bringing you  yeah maybe you can let's go  move a bit there for the camera yes okay  great uh porn  you know there are other pieces also  yeah  i don't need olive oil  ready  [Music]  bishop  okay  night  queen  bishop yes  i also need more  okay did i blunder something no no no  nothing actually  they are about to land there  no if you lose like a blunder night  because the power superior  are you sure let's go for it  i thought it would be  more difficult than this  really  um  again  it's always possible to move the acorn  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  um  check  [Music]  let's go with rook  and rook  we have to simplify the position as  capablanta say extra examples here  [Laughter]  queen queen  brooke  [Music]  [Music]  night  [Music]  um  um  [Laughter]  okay  bishop  [Music]  you see  okay